i'm here with rachel ray everybody
and
we're very excited because our next
guest is coming out she's an actress a
columnist a new york times best-selling
author and she's an amazing mom oh and
her husband's here doing the show with
us jason biggs and she is just amazing
i'm such a food geek fan of hers like
her food is beautiful she makes the
coolest lunch boxes but i've never seen
her make an adult one well here she is
ladies and gentlemen jenny mullin
your instagram page dictator lunches is
serious
you've got game jenny and i really want
to learn from you because i am a huge
fan of your instagram account but it is
for your children yes i do it to
incentivize my kids to eat usually how
did i mean the imagination smart that
goes into it right to make it into a
work of art and to make it interactive
and playful is so yes
i need to tell a story with it i want to
compel them to eat foods that aren't
just like you know typical
kids foods
so
with this lunch when you asked me to do
an adult version of dictator lunches i
thought what a great idea because if i
actually had food with me at all times i
would just be a calmer person you're
amazing dude your lunchbox these are
signature jenny they're making sure
dictator
yes they really they i like how you know
you gives you lots of options and i've
sort of come up with this paint by
numbers type
uh little process where i do a main i do
a fruit a veg and then a snack and then
usually with my kids but also myself
there's a bribe to stay the path right
because sometimes you're in the office
and you're like i'm stressed okay
there's m ms what let's just let that
whole day go up in smoke i'm just going
for the whole jar of m m's it's over now
right like just like put a fork in me
but if i have a little bribe here that i
brought with me i can kind of stay the
course and sort of stay on my like
routine for the day all right well teach
me how to get to the bribe all right so
i'm calling this i always name the
dictator lunches and i'm going to call
this
lunch bring your dictator to work day oh
okay
so that's what we're going to call this
one and for this i'm going to start with
some rice to make this rice more
colorful it also helps for kids i boil
some red cabbage i'm going to eat it
while you're building it yeah please i
boil some red cabbage to make the water
purple and then i just
do the rice in it i mean it's very
simple i'm not i'm i have to have it it
needs to be like you eat very very eyes
first so this is making it much more it
looks more exciting bringing you into
the dish yes um also mushrooms for
adults i'm not a huge mushroom person
but i found that like if you just like
put anything in your oven long enough
with salt and olive oil it tastes good
so if you just
that's the right it's actually true um i
love this squash so the reason i like
this kombucha kombucha squash i call it
kombucha squash but maybe i'm not saying
right correctly um because it's actually
sweet it's lower calorie than like
actually having a butternut squash
and i can just eat tons and tons and
tons of it and i feel like it really
it it acts as like a a nice starchy
wintery
and you just did this thing
right it's just roasted just roasted but
i want to talk about avocados with you
guys because you know so many times i
don't send avocado to school with my
kids because you know brown they say it
browns and then they don't eat it
because it doesn't look like the avocado
they're getting at home i have a perfect
fix for that i cover it i just dip it in
some black sesame seeds the top this is
right
and then fill the middle yeah with like
some white just to be fun this is so
cute right i love this okay it's
delicious
god i'm so glad and then i'm a big fan
of hearts of palm right now they're
amazing lots of fiber they're savory
it's just a fun additional sort of
technology and then finally the bribe so
the bribe i take usually it's sun butter
when it's my kid's lunch i love peanut
butter to me that's not a sacrifice i
love it so i fill it with a couple you
know a couple of these little guys a
couple little chocolate chips and then
since we're doing an adult
an adult lunch let's make it spicy let's
give it a little you know i love that
that huge little salty spicy salty love
sea salt or any type of salt on top of
anything now this is probably going to
encompass my entire mouth but i'm doing
it
oh my god
yeah
so that's how we do it guys
that's how we do it that's how we stay
the course so we're beautiful and so
invented it's just gorgeous
here should we make jason give it a give
it a
sampling cool is this it's delicious
yeah this is amazing i wish by the way
she does this for the kids every day
it's unbelievable she has been for years
i get nothing like this
she's never i've never gotten
you speak so well of each other i do
think that such a big part of parenting
is about how to model love for your
children we don't talk about that a lot
but you guys are just great parents and
i think your kids are going to make
great choices in the future
[Applause]
should we just start making out right
now
your lipstick wait i want to try this
avocado stick on two already don't you
yes do you wear makeup a little makeup i
thought it would be fine i love the
seeds that's such a great idea i know
it's really beautiful
and i want to try these mushrooms
because i am a big fan of mushrooms me
too
it's true
i feel like you could even do the spicy
salt honestly on the avocado yes you
want you can't go there again
you want to go there i think also
avocados always need a little a little
salted olive oil yes absolutely i love
the texture too with the seeds a little
crunch on the avocado it's great i'm
going to it's all can i have this guy i
want to do this guy too yeah all right
be prepared to not
tell them goodbye because you won't be
able to talk goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
you